this is a strange and wonderful brain
one that gives rise to an idea of a kind
of alternative intelligence on this
planet this is a brain that is formed in
a very strange body one that has the
equivalent of small satellite brains
distributed throughout that body how
different is it from the human brain
very different so it seems so much so
that my colleagues and I are struggling
to understand how that brain works but
what I can tell you for certain is that
this brain is capable of some amazing
things so who does this brain belong to
well join me for a little bit of diving
into the ocean you know where life began
and let's have a look you may have seen
some of this before but we're on behind
a coral reef and there's this rock out
there a lot of sand fishes swimming
around and all of a sudden this octopus
appears and now it flashes white inks in
my face and jets away in slow motion
reverse you see the ring develop around
the eye and then the pattern develops in
the skin and now watch the 3d texture of
the skin change to really create this
beautiful 3d camouflage so there are 25
million color organs called
chromatophores in the skin and all those
bumps out there which we call papillae
and they're all neroli controlled can
change instantaneously I would argue
that dynamic camouflage is a form of
intelligence the level of complexity of
the skin with fast precision change is
really quite astonishing so what can you
do with his skin well let's think a
little bit about other things besides
camouflage that it can do with their
skin and here you see the mimic octopus
and a pattern and all of a sudden that
changes dramatically that's
not camouflage and then it goes back to
the normal pattern then you see the
broad Club cuttlefish showing this
passing cloud display as it approaches a
crab prey and finally you see the
flamboyant cuttlefish and camouflage and
it can shift instantly to this bright
warning display what we have here is a
sliding scale of expression a continuum
if you will between conspicuousness and
camouflage and this requires a lot of
control well guess what brains are
really good for control the brain of the
octopus shown here has 35 lobes to the
brain
80 million tiny cells and even though
that's interesting what's really odd is
that the skin of this animal has many
more neurons as illustrated here
especially in the yellow and there are
300 million neurons in the skin and only
80 million in the brain itself four
times as many now if you look at that if
there's actually one of those little
satellite brains and the equivalent of a
spinal cord for each of the eight arms
this is a very unusual way to construct
a nervous system in a body well what is
that brain good for that brain has to
outwit other big smart brains that are
trying to eat it and that includes
porpoises and seals and barracudas and
sharks and even us humans so
decision-making is one of the things
that this brain has to do and it does a
very good job of it
shown here you see this octopus
perambulating along and then it suddenly
stops and creates that perfect
camouflage and it's really marvelous
because when these animals forage in the
wild they have to make over a hundred
camouflaging decisions in a two-hour
forage and they do that twice a day so
decision-making they're also figuring
out where to go and how to get back home
so it's a decision-making thing we can
test this camouflage like that
cuttlefish you see behind me where we
pull the rug out from under it and give
it a checkerboard and it even uses that
strange visual information and does its
best to match the pattern with a little
ad libbing so other cognitive skills are
important to the squids have a different
kind of smarts if you will they have an
extremely complex interesting sex life
they have fighting and flirting and
courting and mate guarding and deception
sound familiar and it's really quite
amazing that these animals have this
kind of intuitive ability to do these
behaviors here you see a male and a
female that male on the left has been
fighting off other males new pair of the
female and now he's showing a dual
pattern
he shows courtship and loved on her side
fighting on the other watch him when she
shifts places and you see that he has
fluidly changed the love courtship
pattern to the side of the female so
this kind of dual signalling
simultaneously with a changing
behavioral context is really
extraordinary takes a lot of brain power
now another way to look at this is that
hmm maybe we have 50 million years of
evidence for the two-faced male all
right let's move on an octopus on a
coral reef has a tough job in front of
it to go to so many places remember or
went and find its den and they do this
extremely well they have short and
long-term memory they learn things in
three to five trials it's a good brain
and the spatial memory is unusually good
and then he will even end their forage
and make a beeline all the way back to
their den the divers watching them are
completely lost but they can get back so
it's really quite refined memory
capability now in terms of cognitive
skills look at this sleeping behavior in
the cuttlefish especially on the right
you see the eye twitching this is rapid
eye movement kind of dreaming and that
we only thought mammals and birds did
and you see the false color we put in
there to see the skin patterning
flashing and this is a lot what's
happening but it's not normal
awake behaviors it's all different well
dreaming is when you have memory
consolidation and so this is probably
what's happening in the cuttlefish
now another form of memory that's really
unusual is episodic like memory this is
something that humans need for years of
rain development to do
to remember what happened during a
particular event where it happened and
when it happened the one part is
particularly difficult and these
children can do that but guess what we
find recently that the wily cuttlefish
also has this ability and in experiments
last summer when you present a
cuttlefish with different foods and at
different times they have to match that
with where it was exactly and when was
the last time they saw it and then they
have to guide if they're foraging to the
rate of replenishment of each food type
in a different place sound complicated
so complicated I hardly understood the
experiment so this is really high level
cognitive processing now speaking of
brains and evolution at the moment you
look on the right there's the pathway a
vertebrate brain evolution and we all
have good brains I think everyone will
acknowledge that but if you look on the
left side some of the evolutionary
pathway outlined here to the octopus
they have both converged if you will to
complex behaviors and some form of
intelligence the last common denominator
in these two lines was 600 million years
ago and it was a worm with very few
neurons so very divergent paths but
convergence of complicated behavior here
is the fundamental question is the brain
structure of an octopus basically
different down to the tiniest level from
the vertebrate line now we don't know
the answer but if it turns out to be yes
then we have a different evolutionary
pathway to create intelligence on planet
Earth
and one might think that the artificial
intelligence community might be
interested in those mechanisms well
let's talk genetics just for a moment
we have genomes we have DNA DNA is
transcripted into RNA RNA translates
that into a protein and that's how we
come to be on the cephalopods do it
differently they have big genomes they
have DNA they transcript it into RNA
now something dramatically different
happens they edit that RNA as an
astronomical weird rate a hundredfold
more than we as humans or other animals
do and it produces scores of proteins
and guess where most of them are formed
the nervous system so perhaps this is an
unorthodox way for an animal to evolve
behavioral plasticity this is a lot of
conjecture but it's food for thought now
I'd like to share with you for a moment
my experience and using my smarts and
that of my colleagues to try and get
this kind of information we're diving we
can't stay underwater forever because we
can't breathe it so we have to be
efficient in what we do
the total sensory immersion into that
world of is what helps us understand
what these animals are really doing and
I have to tell you that it's really an
amazing experience to be down there and
having this communication with an
octopus and a diver when you really
begin to understand that this is a
thinking cogitating curious animal and
this is the kind of thing that really
inspires me endlessly let's go back to
that smart scanner for a few moments and
here's a squid and a camouflage pattern
we zoom down we see those beautiful
pigments and reflectors there the
chromatophores opening and closing very
quickly and then and the next layer of
skin is quite interesting the
chromatophores are closed when you see
this magical iridescent just come out of
the skin this is also neroli controlled
so it's the combination of the two is
seen here in the high-resolution skin of
the cuttlefish where you get this
beautiful pigment Airy structural
coloration even the faint blushing that
is so beautiful well how can we make use
of some of this information I talked
about those skin bumps the papilla
here's the giant Australian cuttlefish
and it's got smooth skin and a
conspicuous pattern and I took five
pictures in a row one second apart and
just watch this animal morph one two
three four five and now I'm a seaweed
and then we can come right back out of
it to see the smooth skin and the
conspicuousness
so this is really marvelous more
skin and you can see it in more detail
here periscope up and you've got this
beautiful papilla and then we've look in
a little more detail you can see the
individual Kapil they come up and
they're little ridges on there so it's a
papilla on a papilla and so forth every
individual species out there has more
than a dozen shapes and sizes of those
bumps to create fine-tuned neroli
controlled camouflage so now my
colleagues at cornell engineers watched
our work and said we think we can make
some of those because an industry and
society this kind of soft material is
under control of shape we're really very
rare and they went ahead worked with us
and made the first samples of artificial
papillae soft materials shown here and
you see them burn blown up into
different shapes and then you can press
your finger on them to see that they're
a little bit malleable as they are and
so this is an example of how that might
work well what a segue from this into
coloured of fabrics and I imagine that
could have a lot of applications as well
just look at this kaleidoscope of color
of dynamically controlled pigments and
reflectors that we see in the
cephalopods we know enough about the
mechanics of how they work that we can
begin to translate this not only into
fabrics but perhaps even into changeable
cosmetics and moreover there's been the
recent discovery of light sensing
molecules in the skin of octopus which
may pave the way to eventually smart
materials that sense and respond on
their own
well this form of biotechnology or
biomimicry if you will had changed the
way we look at the world even above
water
take for example artificial intelligence
that might be inspired by the body
distributed brain and behavior of the
octopus or the smart skin of a
cuttlefish translated into cutting-edge
fashion well how do we get there maybe
all we have to do is to begin to be a
little bit smarter about how smart the
cephalic
it's our thank you
[Applause]